au chapitre sportif l'information du
jour c'est la démission de Bruno Poilpré
le président du Tour volley-ball une
annonce surprise alors que le club a
décroché cette saison son 9e titre de
champion de France et ça onzième Coupe
de France lui expliquer qu'il doit se
consacrer pleinement à la gestion de son
entreprise le groupe Julio plus
d'explications avec Florent Clavel
il quitte le TVB par la grande porte
après deux ans et demi à la tête du club
Bruno poils pré met un terme à son
mandat sur un doublé coupe championnat
un départ au sommet avec le sentiment du
devoir accompli pour celui qui se
présentait à son arrivée comme un rookie
un novice dans le milieu du volley les
deux dernières saisons ont fait cinq
finales
deux victoires un doublées le sixième
une qualification à nouveau en Champions
League quand j'ai pris mon mandat je
voulais maintenir le club au plus haut
niveau dans un top 8 européens si
possible et on y est donc je crois que
la mission a été remplie mais derrière
le satisfait site sportif l'amertume
pointe pour expliquer son départ Bruno
poêle pré met d'abord en avant la
difficulté de mener de front ces
activités de président du TVB avec celle
de gérant d'entreprise mais il y a
surtout du découragement face à la
baisse des subventions de certaines
collectivités sur la métropole une
subvention qui a été amputée de 25000
euros
concernant la région qui nous soutient
la SAS sportive a été amputée de 120000
euros en partie compensée sur le centre
de formation mais pas totalement puisque
on est de l'ordre de 80.000 euros la
présidence de Bruno poil près aura
également été marqué par cette tentative
de name avec McDonald's à la clé 200000
€ annuels de quoi regonfler un budget
loin des cadors européens mais
l'initiative avait été retoquée par la
municipalité tourangelle aujourd'hui
l'adjoint sport estime qu'un nouveau
dialogue doit s'instaurer avec le club
j'ai demandé à nos collègues de la
région de la métropole et du département
à l'automne c'est à dire que quand une
nouvelle équipe sera installée à la tête
du TBB d'accompagner au mieux et de
mieux dialoguer avec les dirigeants du
TVB le nom du successeur de Bruno poil
pris devrait être annoncé la semaine
prochaine il aura la lourde tâche de
préparer la saison prochaine et d'aller
chercher de nouveaux financeurs
et dans un communiqué la région 10
regretter les déclarations du président
des missionnaires du TVB et affirme de
son côté qu'elle continuera à soutenir
le club touranjo comme elle l'a fait ses
cinq dernières années à hauteur de
200000 euros